cet historique l'arbitre française
stéphanie frappard est devenu hier la
première femme à diriger un match de
Coupe du monde de football symbole fort
et logique la France compte de plus en
plus de pratiquants plus de 160 000
cette année exemple à Mont un club qui
vous allez le voir mais tout en œuvre
pour attirer de nouvelles recrues Hélène
chapelet
nous avions rencontré le club en
septembre 2019 à l'époque l'as mon
football souhaitait développer sa
section féminine qui venait d'être créée
trois ans plus tard 90 joueuses font
désormais partie du club avec des
représentants dans toutes les catégories
des U7 au senior l'objectif est donc
atteindre grâce au bouche à oreille mais
aussi à la bonne ambiance qui donnerait
envie d'intégrer l'effectif
en fait il y avait ma sœur de base qui
faisait du foot donc avait commencé un
an avant moi et bah moi je m'étais
désinscrit dans un autre sport et du
coup j'avais envie de faire autre chose
que des sports individuels quand je joue
au foot en fait on pense plus à rien ça
nous libère l'esprit et puis on pense
que à ça en fait et
on oublie tous les problèmes d'à côté et
puis franchement c'est vraiment une
sensation géniale je trouve donc on est
content on a toutes les équipes donc
maintenant c'est de